dick saint louisienne après on attend la
décision de justice les exigences d'un
parcours sans condamnations exprimées
par le gilet jaune risque de contrarier
ce retour les ennuis judiciaires sont
ils aujourd'hui écarté un retour pour
quoi faire avec qui dans quel état se
trouve la commune aujourd'hui et dans
quel état se trouve la droite cinq
visuels et à droite réunionnaise
cyrille hamilcaro ancien maire de saint
louis est l'invité de la politique
jusqu'à 13h vos questions à partir de
12h45 au 0262 99 2000 c'est le carreau
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous me confirmer que
vous êtes bien candidat reconquérir la
mairie de saint louis en mars prochain
c'est une main c'est une évidence
aujourd'hui d'abord parce que je les
écris à l'ensemble des services et des
saint louisienne et des miroirs ont leur
dire que je suis candidat
en effet je suis en capacité d'être
candidat depuis quelques temps je ne
suis pas encore totalement sur le
terrain puisque j'ai encore mes outils
vous avez commencé la campagne
bien sûr quelques mois depuis quelques
mois déjà oublié j'ai déjà commencé
j'avais des contacts avec les
différentes personnes qui me soutiennent
les différents groupes qui sont dans les
quartiers et qui m'aident dans le cadre
de mes campagnes électorales donc oui ça
fait quelque temps déjà
et là je vais qu'amplifier cela dans les
semaines qui viennent puisque je dois
régler quelques petites activités
professionnelles encore sur mayotte et
après ça va aller c'est la honte 2014
aviez été élu pour finalement laisser la
place à patrick mallet parce que vous
aviez été condamné à deux ans
d'emprisonnement et sur 6 40 euros
d'amendé cinq ans d'inéligibilité
comment est ce que vous avez vécu cette
coutume d'appeler une traversée du
désert dont le dans le monde politique
entre on est condamné à de
l'inéligibilité qu est ce que vous avez
vécu là je l' ai vécu peut pas dire
qu'on le vit sereinement je l' ai vécu
parce qu'il fallait le vivre d'une part
parce que ce sont des décisions qui vous
sont imposés et donc vous en vous est
écarté de quelque chose
vous aimez c'est à dire l'action
publique et vous êtes écarté des gens
aussi que vous aimez la population à
partir de là vous faites sans acrimonie
sans regret sans son engeance aucune et
vous fait un parcours professionnel moi
j'ai choisi un moment donné de faire un
écart et donc de partir sur mayotte
exerçait une nouvelle activité
je les ai vécues de manière sereine
aujourd'hui je suis bien bien dans ma
tête bien dans mon corps bien dans sa
façon de penser je suis assez bien il ya
toujours aujourd'hui une procédure à
propos de ces sous sans que vous ayez
continuer à exercer finalement une façon
politique à la mairie alors que vous
étiez inéligible est ce qu'il ya un
risque que vous ne puissiez pas être
candidat ou un risque que vous ayez de
nouveaux candélabres et après il n'y a
aucun risque que je ne sais pas combien
ce que je suis éligible depuis le 12
juin et que depuis cette date j'ai
recouvré la totalité de mes prérogatives
et de mes droits et devoirs est ce qu'il
ya un risque que je ne sois pas demain
en capacité d'exercer les fonctions si
je suis élu il n'y a pas beaucoup de
risques sur ce plan-là je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait parce qu'on est aujourd'hui
sincèrement je n'en sais strictement
rien à être informés je le laisse
travailler sereinement sur ce dossier
mois qu'on peut faire quand on sait que
ça veuille a pas d'histoire qui va
interrompre ne va pas condamner
quelqu'un tout simplement parce qu'il a
exercé une activité bénévole
ça ne s'est jamais vu donc c'est bien
pour cela qu'à un moment donné il faut
savoir raison garder et il faut que
certains arrêtent les fantasmes de
croire que je ne pourrais pas être
candidat simplement parce qu'il y a
encore une affaire en cours que je serai
de nouveau inéligible
ça serait se mettre à la place des juges
que je ne ferai pas qu'est ce que vous
aviez vous même en me semble t-il dit
voilà il ya un maire juridique e patrick
mallet et bien mr pour l'ici que c'est
moi c'est vous qui restez est ce que
vous regrettez aujourd'hui ces paroles
et puis le fait de ne pas avoir réussi à
passer la main
parce que c'est compliqué non j'ai passé
la main patrick mallet a été maire
hilare il a mené sa marque avec la
mission qui lui a été assigné par la
majorité municipale
je pense qu'il a avec l'équipe et
l'équipe
ils ont assez bien réussi dans leur
entreprise de redresser la collectivité
communale pouvait bien maintenant est-ce
que je quelque part est ce que je la
question est est ce difficile de passer
on a vu qu'avec tous les toutes les
personnalités politiques qui ont essayé
dans ce cas là quand on bat les c'est
finalement un dauphin remplaçant on a du
mal à le ne plus interférer ne plus être
là non pas particulièrement
dès le départ nous sommes présentés à la
population
gg très clair mondiale et votez pour moi
je vais être même et peut-être quelques
mois seulement et que mon successeur
dans le cadre de mon départ serait pas
secte aller les choses étaient claires
maintenant dire que je regrette par
exemple d'avoir 10 ah non pourquoi pour
alors 10 gt tête de liste aux
municipales
j'étais lui je garde cette légitimité
politique
maintenant ça ne veut pas dire que ça me
donne le droit de gérer à la place des
autres
pas du tout et c'est ce que je n'ai pas
fait d'ailleurs même si beaucoup
essayent de dire ou de faire croire le
contraire mais c'est leur problème les
rumeurs c'est comme les tueurs ce à un
moment donné ça dessus par france lui
killers
c'est le jeu politique c'est aussi le
jeu politique et moi jusqu'au bout j'ai
envers personne
de parler comme ça de dire ça ou de
faire croire ça je pense que c'est ce
droit entre elles me font beaucoup de
maires de paris par le mouvement des
jeunes avouent contenu critique
vis-à-vis des élus très leur position
soit pour cent les petits robots
financière une politique ou ou par amour
du pouvoir et que pour être un terme à
ça il fallait empêcher tout ce qui avait
été condamné un jour dans leur vie
d'être de nouveau candidat d'être de
nouveau élu je suppose que vous êtes
contre 7,7 cette idée mais ce que vous
l'entendez je l'entends de ceux qui à
mon sens non a pris la pleine mesure de
la constitution française et la
constitution est claire c'est que chaque
citoyen peut s'engager dans la vie
politique de son pays et chaque citoyen
peut être élu donc il peut et il doit
être acteur et il peut devenir l'élu à
partir de là c'est le peuple seul qui
peut choisir comment dans une démocratie
on peut se permettre de dire que le
peuple ne peut plus choisir qui il veut
on va lui donner les personnes entrant
va fixer les critères sur lesquels lui
il sera amené à se positionner pour les
autres donc on revient à un régime
censitaire ou un rien un système de
régime de faveur
ou ceux qui ont le pouvoir ceux qui ont
la puissance définirait les critères
pour dire voilà ceux et celles qui
peuvent fait partie de notre cercle
restreint de pouvoir ça ce n'est pas
acceptable dans une démocratie je suis
allé au crac quand je perds les forêts
je fais pas coup d'état quand je gagne
les élections n 1 je gagnais exerce
pleinement les pouvoirs qui ont été
confiés en temps on ne peut pas se
substituer au peuple ne peut dire je
parle au nom du peuple que celui qui a
été choisi par le peuple
un presse dans l'association il a été
pris et choisis par les membres de son
association il ne peut parler que pas
pour ceux qui l'ont désigné
est ce que vous entendez est ce que vous
entendez ce qui a été dit
barrage qui a été dit à son à ce moment
là deux du mouvement des gillot il ya eu
beaucoup de questions sur le
fonctionnement sur c'est quoi la
conscience qu'il faut la faire changer
on a beaucoup entendu ce à dire mais
comment ce qu est ce qu on peut avoir
des élus qui ont été dans le passé
condamnées qui sont aujourd'hui réélu et
ne pouvant pas ça devrait pas être
possible
vous entendez ce set c'est plus de gens
de plus de gens chantant dans la rue
quand j'entends cela mais on gouverne
pas un pays par mois c'est la voile on
va la faire l'église à masquer les si on
se dit on gouverne un pays par la moelle
c'est fini il n'y a plus de lutte
antiterroriste parce que le président de
la république qui doit ordonner tous les
matins que dieu fait des actions qui
sont contraires à la morale pour même
tuer des gens qui menacent la sécurité
de la france donc si on se place sur ce
terrain là on entre dans le monde des
bisounours
il faut qu'il à faire la distinction
entre un moral et le droit et notamment
le droit politique et nous sommes dans
une démocratie qui heureusement n'est
pas gouvernée par la moelle parce que si
c'était le cas on pourrait faire le
parallèle ceux qui font trop noir un
moment devient des analystes et donc
comme vous pouvez le voir il ya des gens
tellement ils sont enfermés dans leurs
convictions et les croire qu'ils ont
toujours raison
ils vont balancer des galets sur les
charcuteries ou sur des débouchés en
disant je vous interdit de vendre de la
viande mais aucun titre
est ce que est ce que c'est de cette
question de 2,2
par rapport à au casier judiciaire au
passé est ce que vous avez entendu cette
défiance vis-à-vis des élus général
pendant sa retraite qui est bien sûr
mais le fond du problème ne se réglera
pas uniquement de cette seule petite
proposition
le fond du problème vieille quand
quelqu'un dit je n'ai plus confiance
dans la démocratie
la question que j'ai envie de poser ce
que vous avez voté
si vous n'y allez pas taisez vous oui
mais ça revient le la cette ascension
aussi du sens politique elle a aussi
cette idée d'air le vote quelle que soit
quel que soit le lieu
ça fonctionne pas le vote blanc un sens
politique
l'abstention mais n'a pas de sens
politique et à l'adage qui dit qui ne
dit mot consent
si vous vous déplacez pas pour dire ce
que vous voulez vous des pros qui vous
voulez mais votez et voulait pas aller
voter pour lui vous aimez son projet de
voter pour son projet donc c'est une
c'est une manière de voir que je
respecte mais cependant que je ne suis
pas obligé d'approuver tout simplement
parce que l'ambiance globale serait
d'approuver ce jose non je ne crois pas
que même si longtemps même si je le
comprends ce que les autres peuvent dire
mais je crois que la meilleure façon de
changer le pays la meilleure façon de
changer le système c'est de rentrer
dedans et de r acteurs du système pas
d'être simplement celui qui va critiquer
il faut aussi proposer une info route
visiblement il grillait est grillé vous
êtes en liga soucis à marine du mans
gaël c'est un cachalot style cachalot
puisqu'il est lui récupère plus les
déchets que les cannes n'est donc qui
s'est renversé dans la bretelle qui
remonte vers le nord au niveau de
l'échangeur dallas marine donc pour vous
un possibilité d'accéder donc à cette 4e
voie en prenant cet échangeur faut
continuer par l'ancien rotationnelle
passer par le centre-ville le bocage
donc en direction du nord lequel on
s'est couché sur le flanc en que là il
va y avoir sans doute un bon moment pour
dégager la chaussée cette bretelle
dans le sens et stoner je rappelle au
niveau de l'échangeur de la marine de
sainte suzanne
voilà donc pas de blessé semble-t-il en
tout cas pas de gravité mais donc il ya
un portant un nom qui fera sans doute
des moyens lourds on en sera plus un peu
plus tard dans l'après midi
donc je rappelle déviation quasiment
obligatoire par le centre ville de
sainte suzanne
merci merci je grille pour ces
informations lundi politique se poursuit
avec notre invité cyrille hamilcaro vous
aviez en 2014
c'est intéressant car afrique mali
pourquoi est ce que vous voulez
aujourd'hui reprendre sa place pourquoi
suffisamment vous le laissez pas
continuer au pas du tout ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas l'objectif initial en 2014 ce
qui a été dit devant la population de
celui où on se présenter aux élections
c'est chez marc je vous ai dit c'est à
dire je suis candidat s'il n'y avait pas
de de décision de justice je serais
resté
mais s'il y en a une c'est pratiquement
l'équipe et il prends ma place mais pour
un mandat pour les mandats pas plus
si ce qui était prévu c'est ce qui est
toujours prévu d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il
a déclaré lui-même
maintenant notre candidature n'est pas
pour remplacer particulier c'est
simplement pour aller dans la continuité
de ce que nous avons convenu ensemble
ils seraient sur votre liste
ah c'est à lui de décider mais je le
fais tu le sentiment que c'est compliqué
de savoir et les alliances des habitants
qui ont transformé un conseiller
municipal de saint louis dans la
majorité actuelle je pense que c'est les
clans se forment dans ce groupe humain
bien nous sommes des gouttes à vie par
exemple si vous en avez dit s'il ya
toujours deux ou trois qui se préfère et
qui préfère être ensemble plus qu'avec
les autres biens qu'ils soient tous amis
est ce qu'il y à l'écran ce qu'il ya des
dissensions heureusement que tout le
monde ne prend pas la même manière que
de temps en temps il y a des choses
différentes qui sont dites
maintenant il faut qu'il y ait une
cohésion de groupe cette cohésion de
groupe
on ne peut pas le nier a été mise à mal
un moment donné par les décisions de
l'ue ou de deux personnes mais sinon en
règle générale c'est une majorité qui a
tenu contre vents et marées malgré les
difficultés et qui jeux steam est la
bienvenue
elle peut-être encore et elle sera
encore jusqu'aux élections devant ces
murs avec des gens qui seront sur votre
liste dans la majorité actuelle qui n'y
seront pas à ce que votre clan hawiye
fait il n'y a pas de clans particulier
des choix qui vont être faits et ces
choix là seront offertes avec les gens
concernés
ils seront alertés s'il continue c'est
aussi qu'ils me demanderont qui me
diront s'ils veulent continuer à donkey
tout se fera dans une certaine logique
et surtout un certain calme sans qu'il y
ait obligatoirement des tempêtes
après y'en a qui ont déjà choisi de
partir ailleurs ils ont fait ce choix là
c'est l'os c'est leur problème du
positionnement de votre positionnement
politique
on sait bien que on est ici à la réunion
pas forcément dans des clivages
partisans contre avoir le niveau
globalement vous dit vous êtes joueur de
centre droit donc on va dire que
globalement vous appartenez à la droite
réunionnaise hausse en trois sets plus
tôt puis j'ai foncé j'ai la
particularité le mien montrant un qe2
est jeune non mais j'ai la faiblesse de
croire qu'un moment donné les deux
hommes intelligents qui sont se
remettront à se parler et à se parler
vite dans l'internât riom s'ils ne le
font pas aujourd'hui le fonds demain
mais le forain jour demande après ma
reçoivent en a eu des idées mais le fond
ça peut changer quelque chose pour vous
non ce que vous attendez un soutien de
leurs d'autres datant lui
tiens de la et de l'autre mais si je ne
pense pas que ça ne soit pas là donc en
tout cas ils n'ont jamais exprimé quoi
que ce soit qui montrent qu'ils ne sont
pas d'accord avec la démarche
maintenant moi si je peux être le lien
encore entre les deux où entre
différentes personnes
oui je pense avoir fait un chemin
aujourd'hui qui peut me permettre d'être
apaisé par rapport à toutes ces petites
rivalités ou ces petites différences que
l'on peut gommer facilement au vu des
enjeux
vous n'êtes pas pardon de vous vous
n'êtes pas parce que que qu'avec ce
centre parlé tout à l'heure
cette image se sait qu'on avait eues
dans le passé même si vous avez la
possibilité bien sûr de vous présenter
et que ce sont les nerfs qui justement
que vos partenaires éventuels politiques
disent ah ben voilà tout chaud ça
pourrait savourer nuire de le soutenir
j'entends aussi ça de la part de
certains qui ne se sont jamais peut-être
présenter les choses bien mais j'entends
je peux les comprendre
aujourd'hui si je mets mes rejoindrait
parlons non non non entre à 6 le pensent
ils ne l'ont pas dit mais
en tout état cause vous savez il ya une
chose que j'ai retenu c'est que les
rumeurs ce ne sont pas les faits ça
c'est une première chose
deuxième chose la réputation ce n'est
pas particulièrement aussi la réalité et
donc quelle que soit l'étiquette que
l'on peut coller bonne mauvaise quelque
chose que l'on peut penser moi ce qui
m'intéresse moi c'est l'avis des saint
louisiens avec qui je vis et auprès de
qui je sollicite les suffrages et la
confiance après que les autres pensent
ça ne m'empêche pas de dormir avance je
vis bien
je suis actuellement un homme heureux
donc ça je le disais tout à l'heure vous
de centre droit et même si l'équipe
d'ici sont pas forcément ceux qu'on peut
voir livrer ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
c'est être en accord globalement avec le
gouvernement de leur fille avec la
politique globale menée par oméga temps
mais je pense que lorsqu'il ya des
choses qui sont un niveau il faut les
dire bien d'autres qui ne le sont pas du
tout il faut aussi le dire il ya des
choses justement qu'il vous semble
descente à soutenir d'accord ou
globalement tendance actuelle et
d'autres qui que vous réfutez je suis
assez d'accord avec un certain nombre
d'orientations économiques qui sont
prises après real oui je sais libéral
donc je suis à 100 d'accord avec
certaines et notamment la facilitation
de cette entreprise pour pouvoir mieux
mieux secret mais vivent mieux rochers
etc
je suis un peu moins en accord avec
certains projets société moi je ne suis
pas par exemple particulièrement
favorable à l'extension de la pma pour
tous voilà donc il vise à provoquer les
choses qui sont bonnes y ait des choses
qui ne sont pas le système des retraites
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est un
système
enfin la proposition qui est faite de
réformer le système de retraites
aujourd'hui aurait pu être valable dans
les allées où l'économie était assez
forte
les années 50 60 et que l'économie était
vraiment partie les gens pourrait
changer de métier tout en y laver ou
bien ils avaient une linéarité dans leur
situation professionnelle ça pouvait
permettre d'avoir une stabilité même en
scène autres aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
trop le cas donc ce qui est proposé là
est peut-être un petit peu en deçà de ce
qui devrait être proposé et ça ne permet
pas non plus à des gens de se sentir en
sécurité pour l'avenir
qu'est ce qui différencie vraiment
aujourd'hui un programme de centre droit
des autres programmes quand on quand on
veut conquérir une ville recevait avec
ça dans notre village exemple samedi à
saint benoît où les fabrice marouvin
s'il est candidat à saint paul ou encore
dhaheri faire aux avions nous sommes
quelques uns à penser que le en
politique il faut bien sûr la
connaissance politique il faut certaines
compétences aussi un moment donné mais
il faut aussi avoir une vision nyon qui
se différencient pas plus de tant d
autres
alors c'est quoi cette vision de son
3ème édition de centre droit elle est
très simple c'est que aujourd'hui nous
avons besoin de voir un pays qu'ils
soient de plus en plus décentralisée
on ne peut pas accepter aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de décisions
vous posez un dossier défiscalisation ce
dossier défiscalisation n'est pas
traitée dans la région avec le préfet de
région avec le représentant de l'état il
faut ça montre à bercy pour revenir
ce qui n'est plus acceptable dans le
cadre de la mondialisation dans laquelle
nous vivons il faut des décisions et des
réactions sans votre accord
il faut faire plus de jeu la réunion
plus décentralisée pas seulement c'est
une tendance non c'est pas vraiment ça
vous différencie pas vraiment ça ne
différencie pas ce qui nous différencie
peut-être si dans la manière je suis
pour un moment donné on puisse arriver
vers une certaine rupture
à quand je parle de rupture ce n'est pas
de rupture institutionnelle de faire
nous devons avoir des modèles
économiques différencier région par
région en france nous ne pouvons plus
nous reposer sur un système étatique ou
c'est le ministère de l'économie qui à
un moment donné dit qu'une orientation
pour l'ensemble de la nation
certes mais que ce ministère les
goumiers nous donne des règles à voilà
vous ne pouvez pas augmenter vos budget
local à partir des ressources locales
comme prévu par la constitution
eh bien vous ne pouvez pas augmenter de
plus de 1% de 2% aux biens vous ne
pouvez pas être en dessous d'un
pourcentage que j'aurais fixé de manière
arbitraire au ministère l'économie et
des finances en un problème et parce que
ça suffit ça au après dans le cas de la
finance c'est voter comme cela par
l'entente des députés dont pour la
plupart cette annonce juillet des mères
ou n'ont jamais été présidents de
conseils généraux eux et là ça pose un
problème c'est que dans la prise de
décisions pour que ça soit rapide
les jeunes ont dit quoi on veut un
changement dans la vitrine où on veut un
pouvoir un peu plus rapide mais quel est
le pouvoir du politique locale
aujourd'hui rien on a écrit une belle
lettre au président et physiques sur les
neurones et qu'est ce qu'on a fait
contre propositions fusent
si la vous
vous parlez de finalement de mesures qui
sont prises à l'assemblée nationale la
mairie
non la santé et que c'était ce que c'est
qu'un verrou posé comme question mais
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être maire de
centre droit qu'est ce qui différencie
centre droit au maire de centre gauche
de gauche ou de droite ne s'entrouvre
avoir privilégié l'économie
il faut qu'on arrête de dire qu'on peut
donner l'argent distribuer l'argent sans
créer la richesse
or c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
croire il ya longtemps même peut-être
moi aussi quand j'étais élu je les fais
mais quand on s'assoit on réfléchit bien
si on n'a même pas les entreprises on
travaille au corps or on ne peut pas
continuer et là c'est vraiment une
une grande différence l'impôt ne peut
pas être pour ces revient uniquement les
les petites choses de tous les jours
l'impôt c'est vraiment peau et on peut
avoir des infos cher regard des records
qui demande pays plus d'être un bon
encore c'est plus chaleureux
donc en tant que maire demain maire de
centre droit on se dirait et j'irai
l'économie je veux les entreprises
s'attachent que les entreprises créent
des emplois et pas obligatoirement par
contre par contre lorsque le merdy eux
j'aimerais on établisse une zone
d'activités à tel endroit que l'état ne
viendra me dire non c'est trop promettre
la mettait le plus tôt là l'opportunité
c'est le politique la légalité c'est
parler de 2 d'augmentation d'impôts qui
sont quasiment un plébiscite 11 mars et
pas forcément car oui les impôts sont
déjà assez bluffé aucun français n'a
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui
visite à financière de la commune
c'était très compliqué s'était mise sous
tutelle essentiellement pourquoi pour
des dépenses salariales de denrées
comique est trop élevé les comptables de
la chose mais on a fait il y a il y
avait un problème budgétaire important
qui a été due à un moment donné un
certain nombre d'actions et de dépenses
qui entraînait la commune dans un
déficit de 20 millions d'euros
quand été élus en 2014 il était de 12
millions à c'est donc de 20 millions
d'euros en 2009 était déjà le rouge à la
fin de votre à fin de mandat on était à
moins 600 euros
donc parfois il faut aussi six ans une
rose si toutes les communes de france
quoi mais dès qu'on dit pour la première
fois la cette année le budget dans le
rouge en 2009
voilà donc ce qui montre bien qu on
était vraiment dans le rouge à compter
de 2009 quand j'ai quitté la mairie
comme en 2008 pour que mais la question
n'est pas de savoir qui l'a croisé ou
qui n'a pas posé la question c'est de
féliciter ceux qui l'on résorbé
est-ce que ça permet aujourd'hui
marschner de manoeuvre si on travaille
bien et qu'on continue un travail qui a
été initié mais maintenant après il faut
avoir une autre dynamique qui saura la
dynamique de l'investissement et malgré
tout vous est adressée au conseil aux
samples et communaux
vous avez parlé de situation vous avez
pensé quand c'est évidemment par exemple
communaux c'est un espoir d'être d'avoir
un passable un excès quand c'est quand c
est ce qu il ya un risque là de faire
des promesses qui budget compliqué tout
simplement parce que personne ne sait ce
que j'ai dans la tête
et comment je vais le faire non je me
permettrai de l'expliquer au moment
voulu
mais moi je dis toujours ce que je vais
faire avant parce que là pas de surprise
donc il y en a beaucoup qui dit pas mais
à ce stade aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas
dire à ce stade aujourd'hui je cesse
comment je vais le faire je le dépasse
aujourd'hui ce que j'ai quand même je
réserve la primeur aux électeurs et je
ne peux pas me permettre comme ça avant
même de me lancer en campagne de lancer
des idées comme ça certains de vos
opposants s'inquiètent de l'utilisation
de fichiers pour cent vous êtes assez
assez assez employés communaux qu'est ce
que vous avez à ses hauts fourneaux
encore à des fichiers de dons récoltés
je suis élu municipal depuis 1995 et
depuis 1995
je me constitue de manière personnelle
un fichier à seulement les employés
communaux et de beaucoup d'autres
fichiers qui m'est personnelle
contrairement à ce qu'ils disent n'est
pas un fichier des renseignements qui me
remonte les gens qui me disent j'ai été
embauché ah ben je ne travaille plus et
c'est je travaille sur mon fichier ça
sert aussi à ça mais simplement se
balader comme en face à des fins
commerciales
notre part
vous savez c'est très simple de ce faire
d'avoir ce fichier là il suffit de
demander déjà
ensuite tout citoyen tout parti
politique a demandé tout fichier qui à
la mairie notamment la liste électorale
donc il peut l'utiliser conformément au
code électoral
je ne l'utilisent pas ce n'est pas
utilisé dans le cadre activités
commerciales ou de démarches en mai dans
le cadre du code électoral tel qu'il est
prévu que le connais toi je n'ai pas
dépassé ce stade
maintenant ça te pousse des cris
d'enfants sur demande simplement fait la
même chose il ya un tout on a un il ya
un sujet qui revient révérend à chaque
édition
comment est ce qu'on fait pour lutter
contre ce qu'on avait le clientélisme
c'est à dire que je suis bon tous les
militants mais aussi tout simplement les
gens qui viennent voir aujourd'hui
encore le maire pour lui demander un
emploi dans des postes même si il est
pas trop de quoi seront faits pour
définitivement aux petits de soupçons de
clientélisme et et et pouvoir mener une
politique claire et transparente dans
les embauches dans la gestion d'une
commune c'est très sain pour les thaïs
coup recrute à les gouvernements
successifs ce n'est pas l'état ce que
l'état c'est autre chose
les gouvernements successifs sont
hypocrites parce qu'il donne des emplois
aidés ouvert aux associations aux
présidents de collectivités et après il
se trouve qu'il y ait des fonctionnaires
a coûté 10 ou attendez c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut utiliser vous le faites de
manière électorale de lait noir
si on me donne les emplois et à prendre
sinon mais la façon dont vous en
connaissez pas bon la façon dont vous
vous recrutez les gens sépareront vous
choisissez vos amis attendez là
actuellement le gouvernement donne des
facilités aux entreprises pour embaucher
des gens et je suis d emplois aidés par
l'état
est ce qu'on entend les soupçons de quoi
que ce soit je les chefs d'entreprise
pourquoi on dit à chaque fois qu'un élu
recrute quelqu'un c'est du clientélisme
tant qu'on me donnera les emplois sur
vos lutter contre ce sont là ça veut
dire quoi il faut que ça passe par
l'emploi que ces garde-fous l'emploi on
enlève une prérogative importante
un exécutif qui est posée dans le cadre
de la loi c'est qu'il est le patron de
l'administration communale ou
départementales ou régionales
si on lui en donne des emplois des
secteurs qui recrutent non ne l'aurais
pas recruté a sa place et fait le même
je veux dire non seulement vous donner
aux gens le travail à exercer donc on
continue avec ce soupçon de clientélisme
2 d'embauché politicienne ceux qui
veulent lutter contre cela notamment
l'état ne doit plus donner des emplois
aidés tant qu'ils donneront les
entrailles des îles fort on être aussi
en même temps le soupçon de la part de
la population pour dire eh ben les élus
recrée qu'ils veulent mais donc il
faudrait plus en plus de communes mais
qui soit proche mais que eux désignent
ce que les gens vont faire l'état par le
travers le prénom passé choisissent les
anglais et personnes et qui leur donne
du travail à faire dans le sur le
domaine de l'état mais que l'état ne
prenne pas par exemple un agent et lui
dit tu vas travailler aux écoles dans
l'étape raison et lui dit tu vas les
trier les plages va les détruire avis
assez le domaine public fallait trier
les fleuves fallu trier rivière domaine
public de l'état
si l'état donne l ont pas aidés aux
communes ou aux autres c'est aux maires
aux présidents de conseils généraux de
recruter s'il ne veut pas que ça se
passe comme ça qu'ils les gardent mais
qui prennent les agents et qu'il aimait
les sur le domaine public de l'état vous
votre avis c'est bon il faut garder dans
les mairies sont pas les mon avis je
pense qu'avec serait même heureux sur
lui enlever ça parce que personne ne
sait ce que vient vers le matin quand il
se réveille en sortant de chez lui avec
des gens qu'ils attendent de ranger lui
qui attendent devant chez lui en
rentrant le soir qu'ils attendent devant
son bureau vous c'est plutôt vous pour
sa solution que ce que l'état gère
directement sur les ont peur comme ça
les choses sont claires
vous avez été directeur l'association
des maires de la haye ont suscité
quelques remous à l'époque vous êtes
toujours du consultant pour les
organismes publics à mayotte pour des
des intercommunalités société mixte et
tard vous connaissez bien le tout sert
oise la caisse qui fait part aujourd'hui
entre autres qu'il faut y aller aux
élections
qu'est-ce qu'il va passer là trop de
complexité administrative est ce que
c'est le manque de moyens ce sont les
pressions politiques risque est beaucoup
plus vendue dans le petit filet tout est
compliqué les lois évolue tellement vite
et on demande aujourd'hui un élu d'être
un technicien d'être un très bon site
rien d'être un élu c'est à dire celui
qui prend des décisions mais en même
temps il faut qu'ils prennent les
décisions en connaissant parfaitement
tout ce qui existe dans de malaisie
statique ce qui est complètement
impossible donc bien sûr ça décourage
les gens vous en décourage pas les
simples j'ai le cuir tanné moi je
j'ai peur que de dieu de mon père après
le reste ce qui arrive si j'ai mal géré
on me dit que j'ai mal géré ou mais non
mais si j'ai bien géré on va pas me dire
ah oui mais vous avez bien géré mais ce
que vous avez fait pas bon mais c'est
pas à vous de juger si on pas près de le
faire donc ce qui décourage aujourd'hui
c'est que n'importe qui aujourd'hui tous
ceux qui critiquent et tout ça qui n'ont
pas encore exercé responsabilité de le
sympa mais quand on discute par exemple
avec les instances qui représente
l'ensemble des élus ce soir
l'association des mères l'association
des présidents de conseils généraux ou
autres des intercommunalités
on constate simplement qu'il ya des gens
qui sont complètement découragés parce
que il ya des choses qui se passe là
devant chez eux et quand ils agissent
on les attaque ou même parfois pire on
les critique je disais je cite toujours
souvent ça m'inquiète condamné pour
prise illégale d'intérêts tout
simplement parce qu'il a voté une
subvention à une un club de foot de sa
ville un tout petit club dans lequel
jouaient son petit fils et il a dit
allez vous aviez un intérêt parce que
votre petit fils jouer dans ce club
ça devient problématique
le maire qui prend un arrêté hier dans
la semaine dernière un contre les
pesticides dans sa commune il prend un
arrêté le soutien administratif lui dit
non votre arrêté les provinces que ses
parts à vous de le prendre mais c'est à
l'état de le prendre
sauf que l'état ne le fait pas au v à
qui ce retour de la population en
premier vers le maire donc c'est normal
que certains soient complètement
découragé ne veulent plus y avoir de
développement économique qu'elle emploie
demain
un maire est par exemple à saint louis
peut espérer créer parce que finalement
vous avez la main politique et pas par
économique quelques elle qu'est ce que
vous pouvez dire aux jeunes qui chaque
bout dans ce 1er peuvent quelque chose
pour créer de l'emploi
oui elle est petite chose très simple
qui va à l'encontre justement les règles
qui sont posées un peu par un peu
bizarrement c'est dans ma vie beaucoup
de jeunes qui sont d'excellents quoi
faire enfin marc où la loi qui sont
d'excellents réparateurs de motos
sauf que aujourd'hui si ce jeune veut
s'installer
le maire que je suis peut lui donner un
local plus gai écoute voilà où je montre
les structures faites honte anti salon
de coiffure dans ton quartier
sauf que ce cas qui est excellent que
tout le monde reconnaît tout le monde va
chez lui pour soit fait pour parce qu'il
est le jour il veut s'installer en tant
que petit chef d'entreprise il veut
vivre de ce qu'il sait faire et ce
qu'ils aiment faire un gardien ne peut
pas parce que tu n'as pas le brevet de
maîtrise à il faut absolument que tu
passes trop brevet de maîtrise jiva en
cours allez c'est donc pas de l'ordre de
la mairie non ce n'est donc que permet
bien souvent sous développés que peut
faire un maire pour espérer qu'ils aient
des emplois qui se créent sur sa commune
lorsque par exemple créer une multitude
de de ce que j'appelle l'écrire ce que
multifonctionnel contre les petits boxes
et on dit voilà installé vous créez
votre plat et on bute sur ce deuxième
mois je vais vous expliquer des gens qui
aimeraient créer leur emploi et créer
leur entreprise
sauf que la règle aujourd'hui la peau
tellement de contraintes que c'est pas
possible
donc vous avez pas le maintien aucun élu
aura la main sur l'emploi emplois se
créent dans les entreprises l'élu local
ne peut donner que l'environnement qui
permettrai donc là une question
importante dont pour pour les saint
louisiens c'est la question la création
d'un filet où la cressonnière ça
disparaît un peu du dut finalement du
débat moi je pense que ces disparus
prend un bon bout de temps là d'abord
parce que ça a été fait en dépit de
bourse ans par un certain luis je
reviendrai pas là dessus il fallait
tenir le calendrier initial qui avait
été donnée par tout le monde et non pas
essayer de faire un coup politique et
certains conseillers de faire un coup
politique notamment le gouvernement au
lendemain de l'époque ils se sont cassé
les dents parce que il n'ya pas que des
marionnettes qui sont en face et donc la
sphère ne s'est pas fait parce qu'on n'a
pas tué le 1er janvier 2001 il y avait
des bruits mais s'attend voulu jour
politique en pensant qu'ils étaient les
plus malins sauf qu'en droit ou genre
endroit on respecte le droit mais à un
moment donné on a essayé de voir marcher
sur le droit pour faire de la politique
politicienne et ça n'a pas marché
c'est dommage pour les riviérois il
servir mais non warner ou là on n'a pas
pu prendre les simple raison que l'état
ne veut plus en entendre parler vous
remettra isa sur le tapis pour quoi
faire
je ne pense pas c'est la priorité des
priorités
maintenant si demain il faut repartir
sus il faut faire les choses bien
moi je pense qu'il faut faire les choses
bien il ne faut pas simplement dire non
je veux pas au oui je veux il faut faire
les choses correctement
mais si des coups moi je pars du
principe qu aujourd'hui si on parle de
dé pages des communes on va en parler à
l'échelle des harrier peux pas me dire
que c'est lui trop grand écrivain
différences culturelles entre la rivière
la luye sûr mais pas la même chose sur
saint leu et python
si on ne met pas la même chose sur une
commune comme un saint denis et surtout
si on met pas sur la table une commune
comme saint paul avec une multitude de
quartier qui ne se ressemblent en rien
entre saint gilles les bains la saline
et la saline-les-hauts il s'agit de léo
ou même la peine
bon il y à il ya des choses qui font
naître chatham et à l'ensemble
à l'échelle de la région panique au chai
une toute petite commune si nous bézy
trans personnellement vous soyez pour la
lande
j'estime qu'il faudra maintenir telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
ça lui dans sa globalité ça lui
l'arrière
sauf s'il ya un mouvement d'ensemble sur
le sens de la région qui pourraient
faire c'était le projet beaucoup plus
vite à ce moment là je signe des deux
mains pour les bases non pas seulement
208 l'arrière mais je signe des deux
mains pour que nous en avions puissent
se poser la question sur grand bois
qu'on puisse se poser la question sur le
piton on puisse se poser qui sont sur la
montagne et on puisse se poser la
question sur sage il est barré la saline
je compte sur l'état d'esprit la
campagne qui s'annonce
parce que on sait combien sont parfois
rude
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
notamment lors des dernières campagnes
quels sont les adversaires auxquels vous
allez être confrontés durant cette
campagne vous allez me dire que vous les
citer tous mais et l'état d'esprit est
ce que cette campagne risque de se
dérouler depuis 2014
je pense que les esprits se sont
beaucoup apaisée à salluit et c'est tant
mieux
j ai pris ma part parce que j'estime que
nous avons comparé aux tensions de vent
et j'ai pris ma part tant dans les
tensions avant que le rappel monde
aujourd'hui et c'est heureux qu'on fasse
h 1
c'est à dire qu'on ne sort pas toujours
les idiots nous avons été peut-être un
peu idiot à nous en donner d'avoir été
très violent mais c'est tel contexte
c'est après coup que l'on peut résonner
cette manière mais aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il ya un chemin qui a été réalisé à
salluit il y à un climat beaucoup plus
apaisé
tellement apaisées aujourd'hui je ne
parle plus de les adversaires jeudi ce
sont les concurrents donc c'est je crois
que oui ça va être très calme j'espère
d'ailleurs mais deschamps seront faits
dans le sud en ce sens pour que ça soit
très calme il ya d'anciens adversaires
que vous souhaitez retrouver brazeau en
choisit pas à ses concurrents
[Musique]
on les accepte tels qu'ils sont et on se
dit on confronte nos idées et en coup
franc de nos projets que le meilleur
gagne
quant à la campagne
à suivre donc d'ici mars 2020 merci
l'ami car au domaine avec nous dans la
vie politique ce qui est arrivé on va
parler musique passé une excellente
après-midi sur la prière
19h 21h est logique août sur la première
c'est vous qui choisissez la musique ce
soir alors conseiller raconte la ravine
des cabris la barre est là et le maria
nous veut du jean-paul bavol gabriel
alors ce soir l'envié d'écouter un bon
sega est logique août du lundi au
vendredi de 19h à 21h avec elodie sur la
première